[Music]
well that there are different approaches
that people have been working on this is
a very minority group who work in
foundations of physics
so there's a whole approach that goes
back actually to 1925 and Louie
debroglie that's called the pilot wave
theory there's another approach that are
called objective collapse theories and
Roger Penrose is working on those and
some other physicists Giancarlo Girardi
particularly it worked on versions of
objective collapse theories and these
are just different theories and they all
make the same predictions insofar as
they have been tested so far so we can't
go to into a lab and say which of these
approaches is right even though in
principle sometimes these different
approaches make slightly different
predictions you have to think very hard
about how you could actually test them
and what does quantum tell us about
physical reality well that's what's
interesting is that these different
approaches would give you different
answers so if you if I say well I think
it's the pilot wave approach is correct
I'm gonna say well it tells me that the
quantum mechanical wave function is not
a complete physical description and
maybe the world is deterministic and so
on and if I take an objective collapse
theories I'm gonna say that tells me the
world is fundamentally in deterministic
and so there's no single answer to that
the one thing we know for sure is that
there's a kind of nonlocality and this
comes from a theorem of john bell which
doesn't depend on the interpretation
john john bell proved that just certain
results that you get in the lab cannot
be reproduced in a theory that is local
in a certain well-defined sense so there
has to be some non locality where do you
stand amongst these theories all right I
mean I have a slight but this is just my
preference my my aesthetic sense is that
the pilot wave approach seems more
natural to me and the objective collapse
approach seems to me more unnatural but
I wouldn't you know give a lot of
attention to my aesthetic preferences
here they're both very serious there
trying to write the theory down in
completely precise mathematical terms
and everybody should pay attention to
all the going things that are actually
out there that have a chance of being
right for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you